the movie begins in southeast asia where
a group of soldiers take their positions
in the woods waiting for their target to
arrive they use their sniper rifles to
track down a building which is
supposedly housing an illegal company
the company poses as saviors of children
but instead engages in illegal organ
smuggling here we get to know that the
soldiers are from the chinese army and
they are there to bring the company down
one of the soldiers named jin mang is
assigned with the main task of executing
the target song
who is the leader of the salvation
society however he gets distracted when
he notices the innocent children who are
held up against their will ming wants to
rescue the children but his teammate
reminds him of their mission of
executing the target rather than saving
people as ming is busy conversing with
his teammate one of the boys in the
building picks up a glass bottle looks
through it and spots him from over a
mile away ming is left stunned as to how
the boy could see him despite his
perfect position after a while they
learn that seong paw is on his way to
the headquarters meanwhile ming
maintains his focus on the boy and sees
that he is being taken to the operating
room the innocent boy is about to
undergo a dangerous surgery to extract
his heart when ming notices this he
quickly changes his position seeing this
his teammate becomes enraged fearing
that they might fail their mission right
then song paw arrives just as the boy is
about to undergo surgery as a result
ming is torn between saving the boy and
executing his target in the end he
decides to save the boy and fires at the
man who is going to operate on him when
songpaw hears the shooting he
immediately returns to the car but ming
manages to shoot him in his shoulder
following this songpaw's men begin
shooting in all directions killing
innocent children the armies are able to
defeat the enemies but the mission fails
because their target has escaped ming
then saves the boy and decides to raise
him on his own however his teammates
accuse him claiming that seong paw will
now kill more people ten years later we
meet a man named jin tai who is honing
his sniper skills jin tai is revealed to
be the same boy who was rescued by ming
previously and he is now one of the best
snipers in his army batch the next day
jin thai is training with his fellow
comrades the session is led by none
other than the veteran sniper men jin
thai goes through rigorous training and
showcases his exemplary skills however
he always loses to the best sniper in
the batch xiaomei it turns out that xiao
was also rescued from the same location
as jinte and raised by ming in the next
scene jinte is finally rewarded for his
hard work and he is tasked with the
mission of killing song paw when xiaomi
finds out about this the next day she
confronts ming asking why he dispatched
jin tae instead of her but ming remains
silent on the other hand we see jin tae
who has already taken his sniper
position and is watching the enemy's
movements in the monitoring room captain
wang informs ming that they have failed
to execute song paw seven times he also
suspects that someone in their
organization is a salvation society spy
as they are discussing this gente and
his team are spotted by the enemies in
no time they are attacked and ming
orders jinte to abort the mission he
also realizes that wang was correct all
along at the same time songpaw's men
jammed their communication and
monitoring channels making it impossible
for them to give orders to their
soldiers however from ming's
communication line he gets a faint
signal there jinte mentions that he will
not retreat as he doesn't want songpaw
to kill more people left with no options
ming decides to send another team led by
xiaomei however captain huang refuses to
let the team leave until the spy is
apprehended according to the captain
their intelligence has been leaked and
no matter how many men they send the
enemies will only act as live targets
this sparks a heated debate between ming
and wang a short time later their
connection reappears and jintai informs
them that the area is clear but song paw
was not present there jintai then
replays the footage to show how he
accomplished the mission successfully
after this captain wang directs jin tai
to look for evidence jindai obliges and
after a bit of searching he discovers a
laptop containing information on the
sale of illegal weapons drugs and human
organs while investigating further he
discovers a photograph of ming casting
doubt on everyone's belief that ming is
the spy ming attempts to defend himself
but wang orders xiaomei to apprehend him
ming is disappointed that despite his 30
years of service he is still not trusted
as xiaomi is about to withdraw ming's
gun the real spy shoots ming fortunately
xiaomi saves him and chaos ensues it
turns out that not one but several men
from the base were all working for song
paw meanwhile jintai hears the commotion
and immediately rushes to rescue his
people back at the base xiaomei helps
ming fight against the perpetrators
after a while jintae arrives at the
scene and discovers the dead bodies of
his department members he also comes
across a dying wong who informs him that
ming and xiaomei are the real traitors
hearing this jintai is shocked but
before he can take any action ming
points a gun at him ming tells jin tai
to stand down as he is not the culprit
but the latter is skeptical as a result
the duo engages in a professional fight
a few moments later xiaomei joins in on
the action and just when jin thai shoots
at her ming comes in between and takes
the hit meanwhile song paw arrives at
the army base and destroys the building
with a bazooka cut to eight years later
we see jin tai who has now become broke
after failing his mission to assassinate
song paw one night as he is wandering
around a little boy named fang suddenly
runs up to him with a horde of men
chasing him for stealing money fang
addresses the beggar as dad and this
prompts the thugs to go after jin thai
and snatch his money following this
jintai takes feng to his mother min who
works as an escort in a bar jintae asks
that his money be returned but min is
unable to do so as a result jin tai
takes fang to work for him until he is
paid back after a while he brings the
little kid to his place and instructs
him to not steal again from the
following day jin thai and feng begin
their work of collecting used goods
repairing them and reselling them he
also makes the boy read and write like
the other children a few days later min
visits jintai's house to see her son she
is glad to see her son studying but when
fang notices a bruise on her eye he
realizes she has been beaten by her
customers feng then borrows some money
from jin thai and gives it to his mother
asking that she take a few days off
later as jintai and men dine together
the latter reveals that she was forced
into the profession to take care of her
son meanwhile the little kid discovers a
secret box inside gentai's room and
opens it there he notices a deadly
sniper rifle but before he can inspect
further jintae arrives and closes the
box fang suspects that jin thai is a
killer or a cop a butcher or a pig but
jin does not reveal anything to him in
the following scene we see an old man
dining in a lavish room he is none other
than ming soon after xiaomei approaches
him and informs him that they have found
someone whose blood type matches his the
movie then flashes back eight years ago
where xiaomi takes ming to the doctor
after he is shot ming survives but
according to the doctor his wound is
fatal and he will need a heart
transplant every three to five years the
doctor also claims that ming has a rare
blood type which will make his survival
difficult just then song paw enters the
operating room and reveals that ming has
always been his lap dog as soon as
xiaomei hears this she decides to shoot
ming but she is reminded of the time
when ming saved her causing her to
reconsider simultaneously ming regains
consciousness and advises xiaomei to
make her own decision after a bit of
thinking she decides to execute song paw
but her leg is shot by songpaw's troops
when all hope seems to be lost a man
named long infiltrates the place and
takes down all of songpaw's men with his
deadly moves after this ming takes over
songpaw's business with xiaomei and long
as his assistants in the present fang
returns with food drinks and money jin
thai believes he has stolen money again
so he chastises the little boy and kicks
him out of his house a short time later
he recalls the blood on feng's hand and
realizes that he earned the money by
donating blood he runs up to fang and
tries to stop him but just then long and
his men kidnap the little boy jintai
tries his best to save the little boy
but fails following this he heads to the
blood center and finds fang's data he
also beats up the doctor for information
and finds out that the blood is being
sent to the world rescue organization in
the next scene jintai arrives at the
organization disguised as a staff member
inside he discovers several dead bodies
except for fangs indicating that he is
still alive just then the lab doctor
approaches him from behind and injects a
sedative into his neck when jin tai
turns around he recalls that he is the
same doctor who was about to operate on
him in the past enraged he beats up the
doctor and threatens him to reveal
fang's location however before the man
can say anything xiaomei shoots him to
death he discovers that she is in the
other building targeting him with a
sniper luckily before she can cause any
damage gintai manages to escape the room
however he is soon encountered by long
and his men shintai successfully
eliminates several men and comes across
long the two engage in a professional
and fierce fight but shintai's body
becomes weakened due to the sedative
causing him to fall from the top floor
despite this he manages to return home
where min treats his wounds min is
devastated to learn of fang's kidnapping
but jintay assures her that her son will
be returned after some time he puts on
his soldier outfit and gets ready for
war in the next scene using the help of
men jintai draws long out and shoots him
in the arm a whole whilst being more
than a mile away he then chases the thug
and eventually corners him terrified
long accepts to help and takes him to a
place where many children are detained
following this jintai eliminates long in
front of the building's computer
operator and orders him to hack into the
world rescue organization's accounts
elsewhere when xiaomi learns of the
breach she immediately calls jin tai she
tries bribing jin tai with money but he
refuses he then offers her a deal of his
own in which he promises to hand over
their data in exchange for fang left
with no choice xiaomi accepts the deal
and arranges to meet him in the east
city building at midnight after arriving
at the location xiao discovers that a
lady has arrived to retrieve the boy
enraged she fires some warning rounds at
the duo and threatens jin tai to reveal
himself when he doesn't show up xiaomi
orders her men to kill men while
avoiding any harm to fang as they need
his heart soon the mother-son duo are
surrounded by enemies but just then
jintai eliminates them all from a
distance following this xiaomi and jin
tai start their sniping battle while
feng and min try to flee unfortunately
xiaomi captures min and ties her to a
chair turning her into the cover with
time running out jintai selects a
position from which he has a clear shot
the duo then aim and fire at each other
xiaomi shoots at his chest while jintae
shoots at the chair's leg causing her to
fall off the building and die on the
other hand jintai is able to survive
because he had a bulletproof iron on his
body he tells men to escape but right
then his evil father ming appears out of
nowhere and kills her when jin thai
reaches the place he can only witness
ming taking feng away in his car in the
next scene ming arrives at the residence
and begins preparing for the heart
transplant but before they can start
jintai shoots through the building's
bulletproof glass worried ming deploys
three of his snipers to apprehend him
and orders the rest of the team to guard
the building he monitors the shots to
determine jinta's location but the
latter confuses them with remote
controlled shots jintae being the best
sniper dispatches all three of them one
after another he then enters the
building and kills all of ming's men he
soon comes across ming himself but
instead of killing him he removes the
armor and heads to free fang taking
advantage of the opportunity ming shoots
jin tai from behind but jen does not
attack in response seeing this ming
inquires about why he's helping the boy
to which jintai counters by asking why
ming saved him back then this makes ming
speechless and he is unable to shoot his
own son as jintai walks away with fang
ming succumbs to his heart disease and
dies in the final scene jintai is seen
dropping feng off at school and the
little kid now refers to him as dad aka
snipe daddy subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching